Joel might be a Gruff grizzled Survivor
on the last of us but Bella Ramsey says
that Pedro Pascal's onset behavior is
wildly different although it may seem
like most video game-based movies and
television series seem to be destined
for failure from the moment they're
first conceived there's no question that
HBO is the last of us has found a cheat
code to Buck that Trend and while
there's plenty of possible reasons for
its success many fans agree that Pedro
Pascal and Bella Ramsay's portrayals of
tormented Survivor Joel and teenager
Ellie are particularly bright spots as
with the original game watching the
unlikely Duo Forge a close Bond amid an
anguish-filled post-apocalyptic world
has served as the emotional core of the
series Pascal and Ramsay may have
effective chemistry as their characters
in The Last of Us but some viewers may
be wondering about what their real
world's Dynamic was like while they were
filming on set as it turns out Ramsay
has a lot to say about Pascal's onset
behavior during an interview with Screen
Rant Bella Ramsay explains that working
with Pedro Pascal was an incredibly fun
experience from start to finish she
noted that what really stands out about
Pascal's personality is his overwhelming
generosity Ramsay said working with
Pedro was so fun he's hilarious he's
probably one of the funniest people I've
ever met he's also incredibly generous
that's the word that comes to mind when
I think of Pedro she continued he's so
generous with his words with his time
and with his actions he's just a super
cool person to be around and he
definitely made the set a fun place to
be Ramsay went on to fondly recall the
numerous conversations she had with
Pascal while filming as it happens the
pair were able to bond over their shared
Game of Thrones experience Ramsay played
the young lady of bear Island lyanna
Mormont while Pascal played the scene
stealing Oberyn Martell in the fantasy
show though the two characters never
shared the screen it seems like they
still had plenty to talk about regarding
their time on Game of Thrones
specifically Pascal has one object he'd
love to bring from the fantasy world of
Westeros to The Last of Us
really loved my robe
this is why I said clothing I'm telling
you know because
look awesome
as for filming their newest HBO show it
seems that Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsay
relied on each other heavily Pascal
himself confirmed as much during an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
sharing that their Mutual confusion and
sense of unease during the extensive
shoot LED them to become close friends
in no time we never stopped being scared
or were convinced that we were getting
it right but at least we could rely on
each other without question Pascal also
mentions that his bond with Ramsay came
with a side effect as their directors
sometimes had trouble getting through to
them he recalled there was so much time
we got to spend together on set that it
was almost weird when we weren't
together as far as shooting was
concerned there was this fascinating
thing that would happen we were just
kind of in our own bubble no matter what
the last of us may deal with some pretty
dark and depressing subject matter but
it seems that Pedro Pascal and Bella
Ramsey actually spent a lot of their
shared time on set trying not to burst
out laughing when asked about one of his
Fondest Memories from set by augustman
Pascal responded for me it is those
attacks of the giggles I start to think
about what I hear being suppressed
embellished throat like a fungal disease
the contagiousness of the laughter was
brutal Ramsay echoed a similar answer
noting that the duo were most prone to
making each other laugh while trying to
film some of the most gut-wrenching
scenes in the show as the actress
recalled they would laugh even while
talking about our character's dead
family members it would start as a
Little Giggle and then would really grow
by all accounts it seems that Pascal and
Ramsay got along swimmingly on set and
even helped lighten the emotional load
on each other when filming got
particularly intense that positive
dynamic between the two lead actors will
helpfully continue whenever The Last of
Us season 2 finally commences filming
[Music]